die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin
schönen guten abend ihnen allen aus
aktuellem anlass heute wieder ein
intensiverer blick auf krone aber den
nächsten 20 minuten auch viele andere
wichtige themen sport gehört dazu heute
wieder wird katja stresow guten abend
und wir blicken jetzt auf das was wir
für sie vorbereitet haben
verschärfte corona lage in deutschland
die zahlen steigen weiter und die
politik plant strengere maßnahmen
kein schnelles ende der krise in sicht
wären tausende flüchtlinge weiter an der
polnischen grenze aus haren erhöht die
eu den druck auf belarus und
hoffnung im aartal fünf monate nach der
flutkatastrophe klappt die gasversorgung
größtenteils wieder
die in teilen dramatische vierte welle
setzt die politik stark unter druck und
zwingt sie zu einer deutlichen
kurskorrektur die ampel parteien
diskutieren zum beispiel intensiv über
eine impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen un planen jetzt den
ländern noch stärkere befugnisse
einzuräumen und
bundespräsident steinmeier wandte sich
noch einmal eindringlich an alle
ungeimpften der jetzt immer noch zögert
sich impfen zu lassen den will ich heute
ganz direkt fragen
was muss eigentlich noch geschehen um
sie zu überzeugen
ich bitte sie noch einmal
lassen sie sich impfen es geht um ihre
gesundheit
und es geht um die zukunft unseres
landes
gewichtige worte in einer situation in
der wir uns wieder in einem deutlichen
wachstum befinden wir schauen auf die
zahlen seit gut einem monat steigt die
inzidenz immer weiter heute hat sie zum
ersten mal die marke von 300
überschritten das robert koch institut
meldet 23 1607 neuinfektionen
8094 mehr als vergangenen montag seit
tagen immer neue höchstwerte und das
zwingt die politik zum handeln
christiane hübscher
die ampelkoalition ist noch gar nicht im
amt da muss sie ihre pandemie politik
bereits hektisch nachschärfen 3g soll
künftig für den gesamten öffentlichen
personennah und fernverkehr gelten auch
für schülerbeförderung und taxen das
heißt ungeimpfte müssen sich künftig
testen lassen bevor sie bus und bahn
nutzen
was sich niemand darunter vorstellt ist
dass wir jetzt zäune um die bahnhöfe
bauen sondern wenn dann würde das sagen
wir mal in dem wege kontrolliert werden
wie auch fahrscheinkontrollen etwas
stattfinden dass dann die entsprechenden
belege gleich mit kontrolliert wird
verkehrsverbände kritisieren das als
kaum praktikabel fahrscheine impf
genesenen und test nachweise
gleichzeitig zu kontrollieren das ging
er maximal stichprobenhaft wir haben in
deutschland offenes system das heißt sie
haben mehrere möglichkeiten in die
fahrzeuge ein und auszusteigen sie haben
an bahnhöfen und haltestellen mehrere
möglichkeiten auf und abgänge zu nutzen
also wie soll das bei auch aktuell noch
15 millionen fahrgästen pro tag
flächendeckend denn kontrolliert werden
die länder sollen je nach infektions
lage entscheiden können ob sie auch
wieder kontakt beschränkungen im
öffentlichen und privaten raum anordnen
auch die kapazität von veranstaltungen
dürfen die länder beschränken nur den
lockdown für alle den soll es nicht mehr
geben ausgangssperren werden wir nicht
tolerieren nicht weiter zulassen wir
werden auch die schließung von
einzelhandelsgeschäften oder schulen
flächendeckend so in der form nicht also
ausschließen in der länder
öffnungsklausel das ganze vorerst
befristet bis zum 19 märz nächsten
jahres 3g 2g oder zweig plus der
gesetzentwurf der künftigen
ampelkoalition soll alles möglich mache
ich hoffe sehr dass die
ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidentinnen sich darauf am donnerstag
bei der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
einigen können die möglichkeit haben sie
nach unserem gesetz und am donnerstag
auch soll der bundestag das geänderte
infektionsschutzgesetz beschließen
also auf die vierte welle wird jetzt mit
gesetzesanpassungen reagiert aber den
grund für diese wieder extrem
angespannte situation sehen nicht nur
viele mediziner und wissenschaftler
in einem großen politik versagen
allerdings theo koll in berlin wer
sollte sich da angesprochen fühlen die
noch geschäftsführende oder die mögliche
nächste bundesregierung
also für die aktuelle zuspitzungen sind
die geschäftsführende bundesregierung
und übrigens auch die länder politisch
mitverantwortlich da ist in den
vergangenen wochen viel zu wenig
passiert es gab keine aufrüttelnde
fernseh ansprache der kanzlerin keine
auffälligen immer anstrengen und keine
konferenz der ministerpräsidenten selbst
das corona kabinett ist abgetaucht beim
blick auf die mögliche künftige
regierung und die aktuelle mehrheit im
parlament da lohnt sich vor allem aber
ein blick auf die fdp denn da wird
gerade die liberale lehre von der
wirklichkeit überholt die fdp hatte sich
ja während der ganzen pandemie zeit
stark gemacht gegen grundrechtseingriffe
und das hat dann auch zu ihrem
wahlerfolg beigetragen das sollte
natürlich jetzt politisch umgesetzt
werden durch das abschaffen der
weitgehenden eingriffsmöglichkeiten nun
ist aber die infektions lage so
dramatisch wie noch nie also es wurde
immer klarer dass die angedachten
maßnahmen nicht reichen werden und
deshalb trägt die fdp jetzt plötzlich
viel mehr maßnahmen mit als mann für
möglich gehalten hat um es etwas
zugespitzt zusammenzufassen die ampel
wird gerade aus ihren träumen gerissen
und die noch amtierende bundesregierung
aus ihrem schlaf wandeln vielen dank
nach berlin theo koll politik und
wissenschaft haben in dieser partie
nicht immer ein gutes paar abgegeben
eindeutige studien und fakten lagen
zogen in diversen situation jedenfalls
nicht immer eine eindeutige politik nach
sich welche lehren lassen sich daraus
ziehen was bedeutet es für die
gesellschaft und demokratie um das und
mehr ging es heute bei einer
veranstaltung mit dem bundespräsidenten
die daniel paulson verfolgt hat in einer
demokratie gibt es streit austausch von
positionen von interessen diese oft
schmerzhafte debatte können nicht
ersetzt werden durch
handlungsanweisungen der wissenschaft so
der bundespräsident
schon weil es viele unterschiedliche
disziplinen gebe hier habe es wohl schon
zu beginn der pandemie bei vielen ein
missverständnis gegeben
wo politik sich hinter wissenschaft
versteckt oder umgekehrt wo wissenschaft
sich an die stelle der politik setzt
könnte auch sagen wo politiker und
wissenschaftler sich gegenseitig
benutzen um ziele durchzusetzen dann
schwächen wir das vertrauen
sowohl in wissenschaft wählen demokratie
wissenschaftliche expertise also
einschätzung von forschern sei stets
wichtig aber sie müsse immer eingeordnet
eingebettet gewichtet werden ich glaube
das problem liegt in den besonderheiten
von expertise von expertise mehr ist als
bloß eine meinung unter vielen anderen
und gleichzeitig aber auch weniger ist
als
wahrheit objektivität oder neutralität
zentral sei derweil gesicherte fakten
etwa zur impfung zielgruppen genau zu
erklären viele die zweifel haben seien
erreichbar aber nicht erreicht worden
man muss diese gruppen abholen mit ihrer
jeweils spezifischen sorge da gibt es
die jüngeren frauen die haben angst um
ihre unfruchtbarkeit das ist aber nicht
das thema bei vielleicht berühmten
fußballerinnen und fußballern da geht es
dann vielleicht eher um diesen berühmten
langzeitwirkungen auch das aber etwas
was man sehr gut erklären kann
selbstkritische töne auch aus der
politik auch dazu dass die parlamente
oft nicht zentraler orte debatte war
und wir haben uns selbst ein stück weit
werk würde ich sagen in dieser zeit wir
haben uns ein stück weit zurückgenommen
weil wir dachten das erfordert die
situation wichtig sei zudem so
steinmeier dass politiker stets
offenlegten welche experten sie
einbeziehen welche fakten und
werturteile und welche unsicherheiten es
gebe
die instanzen steigen was macht die
politik so heißt unser zdf spezial
direkt im anschluss an diese sendung
bislang sind impfungen jahren
nachweislich die einzige große hilfe im
kampf gegen korona aber auf den
belasteten intensivstationen liegen
überwiegend ungeimpfte hoffnung und
vielleicht die wände könnten neue
medikamente seien eines bekam jetzt die
zulassung für die eu in sachsen anhalt
kam es schon sehr erfolgreich zum
einsatz wir uns jetzt andreas weise
zeigt
städtisches klinikum dessau corona
station seit märz werden hier cobit
infizierte mit antikörpern aus dem labor
behandelt mit großem erfolg die
sterberate oder auch die zahl der
patienten die auf die intensivstation
mussten sank deutlich
insofern sind sehr wir wirklich sehr
sehr zufrieden mit den
mit dem einsatz dieser medikamente auch
die krankenhausverwaltung hat sich hier
sehr deutlich reduziert von 17 tage auf
neun tage ist auch wichtig dass
patienten ja nach hause kommen die
medikamente werden per infusion
verabreicht zwei von ihnen aus der
schweiz und südkorea haben nur noch eine
offizielle zulassung in der eu erhalten
viele patienten waren im vorfeld
skeptisch fühlten sich quasi als
versuchskaninchen doch stationsärztin
pannier konnte bisher fast alle von der
behandlung überzeugen
dass es keine nebenwirkungen gemacht hat
also muss man auch sagen wir bis jetzt
keinen einzigen patienten mit einer
nebenwirkung gesehen und zum anderen
geht es den patienten sehr rasch
deutlich besser risikopatienten ab zwölf
jahren können nun gezielt behandelt
werden zumindest eines der zugelassenen
mittel seien nach unternehmensangaben in
deutschland in ausreichender menge
vorhanden
für die ärzte in dessau ein meilenstein
bei der bekämpfung des virus
den ersten sieben tagen nach beginn der
symptome haben wir jetzt einen
medikament mit dem wir behandeln können
das ist auf jeden fall ein game changer
auf jeden fall game changer vielleicht
ein wendepunkt also im kampf gegen
korona kurzfristige immunabwehr die aber
kein ersatz für eine impfung ist
ziemlich interessant und mehr zu den
medikamenten für komapatienten gibt es
auch bei zdf wiso gleich um 19 uhr 40 ja
so viel zu corona jetzt zu den
koalitionsverhandlungen die spd grüne
und fdp in berlin fortgesetzt haben nach
gesprächen in arbeitsgruppen vergangene
woche haben sich jetzt wieder die
spitzen der parteien getroffen um ihnen
kernteams die noch strittigen fragen zu
klären und die soll es unter anderem in
den bereichen klimaschutz und finanzen
geben mehrere
nichtregierungsorganisationen
forderten einen stärkeren einsatz für
umweltschutz und menschenrechte
in mecklenburg-vorpommern war und bleibt
sie weiterhin die chefin manuela
schwesig wurde heute als
ministerpräsidentin in ihrem amt
bestätigt und sieben wochen nach der
landtagswahl
gleich im ersten wahlgang hat geklappt
allerdings mit zwei stimmen weniger als
das rot rote regierungslager stimmen hat
die spd politikerin wird künftig mit der
linken regieren im neuen kabinett zum
ersten mal mehr frauen als männer
wegen der dramatischen situation an der
bieler russisch polnischen grenze hat
die eu neue sanktionen beschlossen sie
richten sich auch gegen unternehmen die
das vorgehen von machthaber lukaschenko
unterstützen und jetzt scheint bewegung
in die festgefahrene lage zu kommen
schon in den vergangenen tagen hatten
die türkei und eine syrische airline
migranten untersagt ihre flugrouten
richtung belarus zu nutzen jetzt wollen
der irak und auch belarus selbst
menschen von der grenze wieder zurück in
ihre heimatländer bringen gunnar krüger
berichtet der flughafen von mit sie
glauben an eine flucht wie aus dem
katalog es ist einfach das visum gab es
im irak für 2040 dollar
belarus wecke diesen glauben sagt die eu
die außenminister ziele nun mit neuen
sanktionen auf den apparat des macht ich
bin wirklich sehr froh darüber dass die
europäische union sich in allen fragen
sehr geschlossen zeigt dass all
diejenigen die sich an den schleusungen
beteiligen die lukaschenko in die wege
leitet von der europäischen union
sanktioniert werden was sie beschließen
das wirkt schon airlines streichen minsk
vom flugplan und lukaschenko bietet
einen menschen wie er rief in ihrer
heimat zurückzufliegen nur sein die ja
so stur so windig dieses angebot so
konkret das ziel von eu kommissaren
chinas er besucht den irak heimat vieler
flüchtlinge und fordert im zdf
die regierung hier muss in
zusammenarbeit mit dem belarussischen
regime ihre rückkehr organisieren beide
seiten haben wir das in sicherheit die
meisten migranten in belarus kommen aus
dem irak deshalb versucht die eu
kommission hier die irakische regierung
zu überzeugen jetzt ihre bürger
zurückzuholen einfach wird das nicht
denn erstens haben die migranten viele
tausend euro bezahlt um ein ticket nach
europa zu lösen und zweitens hat die
irakische regierung bislang wenig
interesse an einer rückholaktion gezeigt
so versucht die eu migration zu steuern
und kann sich die partner nicht
aussuchen
im polnischen bial ist organ der grenze
zu belarus ist anna fest für uns an wie
ist denn die situation was passiert dort
vor ort
ja wir stehen hier vor dem hauptquartier
des regionalen grenzschutzes und was wir
beobachten konnten in den letzten
stunden waren auffällig viele
militärfahrzeuge die sich auf den weg
gemacht haben richtung grenze dort im
grenzort kubica sollen mittlerweile
3500 migranten verharren design
ausgestattet worden von bella russischen
soldaten mit tränengas mit werkzeugen
und sie haben erste gesammelt um ein
sturm auf die grenze vorzubereiten ob
das so stimmt können wir nicht
verifizieren wir als berichterstatter
dürfen nicht durch die sperrzone dürfen
nicht an die grenze es gibt allerdings
ausnahmen von bella russischen fernsehen
die zeigen ähnliche szenen tausenden
migranten die eben auf bella russischer
seite vor dem grenzort cousine zwar
verharren die belarussen widersprechen
den polen und sagen die migranten hätten
sich eigenständig organisiert ob das
stimmt ist höchst fraglich also die
situation bleibt angespannt vielen dank
an der fall ist
in großbritannien gilt seit heute die
zweithöchste terrorwarnstufe
anschläge werden damit sehr
wahrscheinlich als sehr wahrscheinlich
eingestuft grund ist natürlicher vorfall
gestern in liverpool dort war vor einer
frauenklinik ein taxi explodiert ein
fahrgast hatte sich dorthin bringen
lassen er wurde getötet die polizei geht
davon aus dass er den sprengsatz mit
sich trug es gab vier festnahme aber
über die hintergründe ist noch nichts
bekannt
der winter naht wir sitzen in geheizten
räumen aber in den
überschwemmungsgebieten in nordrhein
westfalen und rheinland pfalz bank man
noch weil im aartal zum beispiel in
vielen beschädigten häusern noch heizung
empfehlen zwar ist eine neue gas trasse
in der rekordzeit von nur drei monaten
fertig geworden aber viele menschen
werden trotzdem mit provisorien
überwintern müssen marion geiger
berichtet
rohr für rohr wird das gasnetz geflickt
in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler immer mehr
haushalte werden wieder versorgt frau
von regius stahl freut sich für ihre
mutter die 97 jährige musste die wohnung
verlassen ohne heizung und warmes wasser
konnte sie hier nicht bleiben nun kann
sie endlich wieder heim
für alle eigentlichen segen dass man
dann wieder den stück normalität bekommt
und ich habe meine mutter auch wieder in
ihrem mal in ihr reich sein kann und
nicht frieren muss die flut hat viele
kilometer gasleitungen zerfetzt und
beschädigt doch die instandsetzung kommt
schneller voran als zunächst gedacht und
das netz wird bald repariert sein wir
haben etwa 80 prozent der haushalte die
am gasnetz angeschlossen sind bereits
wieder versorgen können wir haben es
also auch wieder warm wenn sie eine
heizung haben und die die restlichen 20
prozent werden wir bis ende november
geschafft haben das problem in etwa 3000
haushalten sind die heizungsanlagen
zerstört worden für die noch bewohnten
häuser muss es notlösungen geben die
hilfsorganisation arche baut klimageräte
allen finanziert durch spenden
mit diesen können die menschen einen
raum effektiv reizen
unsere anlage sagt man knapp drei
stunden montiert das heißt wir bringen
auch schnelle wärme wie viele flutopfer
im kalten ausharren ist unklar die
energieagentur rheinland pfalz bittet
betroffene dringend sich zu melden um
ihnen gezielt hilfe anbieten zu können
haben wenn man sich bei uns meldet
sondern wir sind dafür da ist die
versorgung mit wärme eine schlüsselfrage
im winter nach der katastrophe
wir machen jetzt sportlich mit
fußballern hat der stresow weiter genau
nationalmannschaft ist das thema und
fußball bundestrainer hansi flick kann
sehr zufrieden auf sein erstes
bundestrainer ja blicken sieben siege in
sieben spielen der letzte gestern abend
in der wm-qualifikation beim 4 2 1 in
armenien
ilkay gündogan war die schaltzentrale im
mittelfeld und steuerte gleich zwei tore
bei seinem foulelfmeter vor der pause
folgte in der 50 minute ein schuss dem
armenien schlussmann ins tor fall
trotzdem glaube ich dass wir gut
herausgespielte tore geschossen haben
wie beim doppelpass mit müller als jonas
hofmann das 1 0 durch kramers
vorbereitete und der stark aufspielende
gladbacher sorgte dann auch für den 4 zu
1 endstand
wichtig ist jetzt dass wir im märz alle
da weitermachen wo wir jetzt aufhören
die qualifikation locker überstanden
erst im märz geht es dann weiter für
hansi flick auf der wm mission mit dem
nächsten testspiel jetzt zum tennis und
den atp finals in turin italien dort hat
alexander zverev sein auftaktspiel
gewonnen vorzeitig denn deutschlands
nummer eins hier im bild unten spielte
gegen den italiener matteo wäre teenie
der im zweiten satz mit muskulären
problemen aufgeben musste nächster
gegner von alexander zverev ist morgen
der russe medwedew
und gestern abend überschlugen sich die
pressestimmen nach lewis hamiltons
überragendem sieg beim formel 1 grand
prix in brasilien wenn man einige
zusammenraffen würde käme man auf der
göttliche superstar hamilton liegt als
tornado über verstappen hinweg
als er aus seinem mercedes stieg wusste
lewis hamilton dass er mehr als nur ein
rennen gewonnen hatte auf startplatz
zehn strafversetzt musste er miterleben
die sich sein großer widersacher max
verstappen nach der ersten kurve an die
spitze setzte davon unbeeindruckt räumen
zu hemmen das feld von hinten auf und
hatte schon nach 19 der 71 runden nur
noch verstappen vor sich die
entscheidung dann in runde 58 als der
niederländer im red bull seinen
kontrahenten nicht mehr standhalten
konnte hamilton vor fast hatten und
weiter reporters das titelrennen hat
wieder fahrt aufgenommen
ja nur noch drei rennen und verstappen
hat nur noch 14 punkte vorsprung dann
vielen dank kann ja leider begleitet uns
das graue wetter noch ein bisschen aber
wo sich morgen trotzdem sonne zeigt ein
vergleich von katja riefler im heute
journal um 21.45 begrüßt sie claus
kleber und morgen genau an dieser stelle
jana paris schön dankeschönabend und bei
uns geht es jetzt weiter mit dem zdf
spezial zur corona lage
[Musik]
guten abend hochnebel bereitete sich
heute aus von den baltischen staaten
über polen skandinavien ganz deutschland
weiter in richtung niederlande belgien
luxemburg und überdeckte auch fast ganz
frankreich ja sonnenschein gab es
wirklich nur selten in mitteleuropa aber
in deutschland gab es doch einige
wolkenlücken hier zum beispiel auf dem
fichtelberg im erzgebirge aber auch an
der donau und am alpenrand da wo es
jetzt mal vorübergehend klar war da
bildet sich in der nacht wieder dichter
nebel sonst bleibt es meist bedeckt und
die temperaturen sinken auf sechs grad
auf den ostfriesischen inseln und in
ostfriesland und bis auf minus 1 grad in
mittelfranken im osten und im süden ist
es also kalt genug da wird es am boden
frostig und es kann also auch glatt sein
morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen im
sauerland bei vier grad fünf grad werden
dass in westlichen sachsen oder auf der
schwäbischen alb sonst gibt's meist
sechs bis acht grad wir haben aber auch
zweistellige temperaturen hier in der
lausitz oder auch am alpenrand mit zehn
grad wenn da mal kurz die sonne
rauskommt das ist dann dem südöstlichen
wind zu verdanken auf der nordseite des
erzgebirges auch nördlich von berlin
oder an der donau und in den nächsten
tagen kommen dann von norddeutschland
etwas regen heran sonst ändert sich
wenig guten abend